one in five american veterans who were
deployed to iraq and afghanistan have
suffered from post-traumatic stress
disorder one former british soldier has
found a unique way to rebuild after the
trauma of his service tore his life
apart roxanna sabri visited him in wales
to see how he is now helping others
day after day
mikey allen hauls stone
after heavy stone
and log after log up a mountain in wales
so this is it
yeah this is the castle i've been
building now for the last three years
ellen didn't plan to build a castle at
first
but as the foundation took shape he
began rebuilding something else his
spirit the goal has created some form of
hope has kept me
um alive to a certain degree
kept you alive yeah i think so
wow
skill and luck kept him alive when he
served with the british army in
afghanistan over a decade ago but death
was never distant one day on patrol he
saw an afghan police officer step on a
taliban mine
what happened then
there's a big explosion me and my
colleague went sideways getting across
the floor
best way to describe it looked like his
legs have been stuck together with super
glue just all different directions his
torso was twisted sideways
back in wales allen suffered from
post-traumatic stress disorder
you come back and you feel a different
person he left the army and turned to
drinking and drugs his marriage broke
down
and one day so did he
and that's where i just kept eating
painkillers and eating them and eating
them
but i hope not to wake up
but you woke up
i woke up the next day and
that's when things went really bad
though to be honest
homeless alan searched for solace in the
solitude of these mountains he made a
wooden cabin but within months local
authorities demolished it sending him
spiraling again
then a nearby farming family learned of
allen's plight and gave him a chance to
start over on their land
as ellen pushed his body to its limits
carrying up to 130 pounds of stone at a
time
and chopping logs barely resting he
found purpose and calm
putting the stone together it's like
mindfulness like a giant jigsaw so you
can kind of
just forget be in the moment yep please
and he found love again
rachel whiting lost her husband who was
also in the military to suicide in 2011.
for me that night
it was complete
and utter hell
it's a pain that will never go
as
this place helped at all
being here and helping him and him
helping me
we've grown so much
and even when i feel like i don't want
to do much and i'm having one of those
days
you'll see you sure you're doing a
chopper tree time with me are you sure
you don't want to come down and just
just try one stone run come on oh all
right and three
two as the castle has grown their
community has too
each week around a hundred people visit
local residents other troubled veterans
strangers inspired by the 42 year old
through his charity called ndx allen
offers fitness sessions skills training
counseling a sanctuary nestled in nature
and hope as bad as things are there's
always a future it's that belief the
belief is important
trauma therapist gareth noble says like
his friend alan we all face adversity
how we overcome it is up to us
do we need to build a castle
a castle in a height a castle in here
alan now lives in a nearby village but
his journey goes on i think i'm still in
the healing process to certain degree
what will it take for you to feel that
you've healed
there won't be need for me to keep doing
this
he plans to finish the third and final
floor in the coming months
more space for more healing
for cbs mornings roxanna suberi in the
sir howie valley wales
no matter what happens when things fall
apart you can always rebuild